well hello there watching the press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages time to see then what's
making the headlines with the editor of
nottinghamshire live natalie faye and
the former advisor to boris johnson kill
the ranger we'll hear from them in a
moment first though let's take a look at
the front pages we're reacting to the
murder of conservative mp sir david amos
the sunday express declares we won't let
terra win
the sunday mirror with a nearly
identical headline
the sunday telegraph reports that the
man arrested in connection with the
murder had previously been flagged to
the government's prevent programme for
counter-extremism
well the sunday people pictures sir
david at a family wedding
writing in the observer the house of
common speaker lindsey hoyle insists
that david's killing must bring about a
change in the nature of current
political discourse
well let's bring in our guests tonight
natalie and culver welcome to both of
you and certainly a a sad day to reflect
on what's happened
most of the newspapers leading on the
death of sir david and uh culver your
your headlines really what you take from
what we've heard today from so many mps
who've both paid tribute and discussed
mp security
oh culver have you can i just ask you
have you muted yourself can i just check
how is that honest perfect yes right do
start again thank you
deeply distressing news deeply tragic
incident and yes it sent shock waves
through i think the broader public um as
we've been through all these challenging
times over the last few years in
political discourse but this lovely man
who as we've heard so much about um over
the past a few hours and 24 hours or so
since his tragic death
but also the repercussions around what
it means for politics what it means for
people in politics and how we protect
our democracy
we go through the roughing tumble of
politics in this country we've had
elections we've had brexit we've had
all kinds of things going on in the last
few years very volatile very divisive
but
i think we still are a cradle of
democracy and our democracy has been
tested now when things like this happen
it really does challenge us it
challenges us all to think about how how
we engage in our politics
what the politicians do and say and
individually the jobs they have the
responsibility that they the burden that
they bear and how we the rest of us even
us as uh the commentators but everyone
out there who comments and reflects on
it what are we adding to society what
kind of society do we want to live in
and i think this tragic event it
shouldn't happen
it's it's it's not right but it makes it
brings into sharp focus what it is that
we need to think of and value in our
politics and how we really should treat
each other i think especially we see
that in all kinds of uh social media uh
and very somethings that have just been
just been horrific over the last few
years if i'm honest to say uh and and i
think we need to we need time to address
this now
yes but sadly much of what you just said
was also said after the murder of joe
cox wasn't it so we're we're back there
effectively um but you if we look at the
sunday uh express uh tonight uh natalie
that unified picture from the
politicians uh going to the scene today
uh with their reads as well sakir
johnson you know does that help do you
think with this message that we can't
let terrorism win that democracy needs
to win the day
yeah i mean i think that's a really
powerful image isn't it that united
front that we've seen there from all
political sides and in fact this evening
we've heard that nobody's going to be
contesting the by-election when it
happens which is exactly the right thing
to do
but you know moving forwards what's
going to happen as we've already said
how will mps be able to work now do they
need police protection will that put
people off coming to see them um you
know that special relationship that mps
have
uh in a democracy like ours is now you
know being questioned and it's under
threat
um but
i think it's something that all
political parties need to join together
on and think about how we're going to
move forward now how can we protect mps
and the special place they have in
society
um
and you know learn from this and and
protect everybody it's such a tragic and
difficult situation
and those images today were really
powerful
you can see
on the screen yeah we see pretty patel
obviously the home secretary there who
you know reiterated that a review is
underway into mp security
many decided to carry out their
surgeries uh did they not last night and
today culvir
but others like david lammy who was on
his radio show explaining that why have
we got to a situation where people like
him need panic buttons and bulletproof
grass glass at their homes you know he
now has to have his surgeries in civic
centers where there is already security
um perhaps a different decision for
urban mps to rural mps who have to
travel distances as sir david amis had
to be fair to get to to leon c
so different mps already taking
different decisions about this but does
it need to be unified do you think does
there need to be some clarity from the
police too about how seriously they take
threats made to our politicians
i think mps will do what they should do
and take a personal view on it but i
think you also right-handed that there
does need to be stronger guidance now
because as you said what i mentioned
earlier
a lot of people said and we heard after
the tragic killing of joe cox
mp but really we've seen the decay in
the nature and the discourse in our
politics i've been involved in politics
for almost 20 years i've stood in a
general election there's no bigger
privilege than asking and campaigning
around a constituency uh i've worked in
public office for the mayor of london
for four years um i saw the challenges
when we're we're engaging this is the
brilliant thing about politics is that
frontline engagement with the public
listening to their views and politicians
must have that access they must have
that ability and the public must have
access to them
but we've also seen over and i've seen
it over the last 20 years the challenges
that friends of mine have faced as mps
uh as politically elected officials uh
the increasing threats uh the increasing
uh vitriol um and some of it driven by
the divisiveness of campaigns and how
campaigns have been led and some of it
you know politicians have to look at
themselves as well how they've run those
campaigns and the things they say about
each other and i think
that you know sir lindsay hall in the
observer on the front page is saying you
know there needs to be a kind of society
and we need to look at how the discourse
in politics is taking place i think he's
right uh speaker of the house he sits at
the center of the crucible of our uh
political establishment and he has a
huge amount of influence and i think i
hope he takes this opportunity from
these tragic circumstances to do
something and all politicians do
but they will need to review uh what
their personal security is and i think
the police do need to be involved in
that in understanding how do we keep
people safe in the current environment
yes the the nature of discourse
political discourse is certainly the
lead for the observer we must end the
hatred aimed at our mps again quoting
sir lindsay aimed at our mps and even by
our mps many have said mps themselves
need to uh to clear up their own
language don't they natalie
uh yeah i mean you know i know from the
mps that i cover in my patch um they've
suffered at the hands of trolls death
threats it's affected the family life i
mean um
you know ben bradley who's the mp for
mansfield he's he was very outspoken uh
and that's what his constituents wanted
him to do they were representing him and
he was uh speaking you know a lot of
views that they supported he's a very
popular mp in his area but we did an
interview with him earlier this year and
he spoke about how he'd had very serious
threats and he's got two young children
his wife had told him to you know just
sort of tone himself down a bit really
and um
that's a threat to free speech and all
democracy and what mps are supposed to
be doing
um on the other side of the political
spectrum we've got someone who um is
another nottingham or nottingham east mp
nadia whittone uh also completely
different views to ben bradley but has
also suffered very serious incredible
death threats and lots of trolling she
actually cancelled um the opening of her
constituency office last night which i
was invited to she cancelled it off the
back of this and i think there's real
fear among mps um you know because of
those threats that they're getting
it's just terrible but what can we do
about it i don't know the answer i don't
think anyone knows the answer at the
moment
but mps do need more protection but in
what form that comes nobody knows that
either
many of uh tomorrow's newspapers are
leading culver on the investigation
sky news is a defense and security
editor naming the suspect tonight is ali
habi ali
25 year old britain of somalian heritage
the mail on sunday suggesting that he
was the son of a well-known somalian
government official
sky news also understands he was known
to the government's prevent scheme the
sunday telegraph reporting that too that
he had previously been referred to the
government's counter-terrorism programme
elsewhere the sunday times suggesting
the suspect is believed to be a
self-radicalized loan operative known to
counter-terrorist police and is known to
have been referred to prevent the
anti-extremism program
the details obviously in the newspapers
as we await more information we've heard
from the
met police tonight too that they are
able to hold this suspect now until
friday the 22nd of october
but this will also form a very
important part of the narrative about
the sorts of threats that mps are under
right now
it will anna and unfortunately you know
if this is and it looks like a terror
attack it's you know i won't comment too
much on the individual i know it's very
early in the reporting and the
investigation but yes that that takes
another tilt and you know this tragedy
but i think fundamentally
we we have to look at all round security
we have to look at what is it that
mps elected officials need to do to go
about their business to be in touch with
their constituents and how we can best
enable them to do that without losing
that touch but enabling their security
to be improved i think you know this is
the time now where we need to look at
several things yes physical security
but also
um when people are talking to each other
what kind of messages they're sending
because we know that some other the
commentary some of the language that's
used and we've touched on the discourse
can be inflammatory and we've seen uh
you know huge expansion in broadcast
media nowadays i think we've all seen it
it's gone from rolling news on sky to
everything on radio other news channels
and there's content required and
sometimes it needs to be more
opinionated and even dare i say more
shocking i think we need to consider
that as we go forward because it can it
can ignite certain kinds of reactions in
people so there's there's the physical
security there's the discourse in public
and there's the media and the type of
things that we're broadcasting and how
we're broadcasting i think all areas
need to be examined and i really hope
they will do um but they should do they
should have been done many times before
it's a tragedy that it takes this kind
of in this kind of incident to really
bring it to the fore again
and what we've learned natalie about sir
david amos he was really a flag bearer
for constituency cmps put his heart and
soul in it um their problems were his
problems he picked up on the things they
were concerned about but as we looked at
the sunday people too
he was also a devout and devoted family
man
um and his own as they put it haunting
words my family pay a big price for me
being an mp pictured there at the at the
wedding recently of one of his his
daughters and and sadly that is entirely
true is it not uh tonight
it is yeah and i think a lot of mps
would you know absolutely agree with
that uh i mean what we're hearing about
sir david is he was one of those great
constituency mps we all know them
you know most mps are like this they
just get on on the back benches with
doing work for the people who've elected
them he campaigned for endometriosis you
know one of those conditions that many
women suffer with but so many people
know very little about he was a a really
passionate animal rights campaigner
taking on these kind of issues and there
was a lovely interview today with
someone who owned the stables nearby and
she said he would always just come in
and just kind of barge in and be with
the horses and
he just sounds like a fantastic man and
obviously um the people of south end are
now also calling for um the town to be
made a city which is another of his
really uh passionate campaigns he had to
make south end of city and i wonder if
that will actually uh you know become
his legacy that would be fantastic to
see that um another pitch was quite
striking of him in the past few days was
um when he was knighted he dressed
oh i think we might not hear that story
um apologies we just lost natalie just
very very quickly a final thought from
you culvere uh that many people have
said david davis included that actually
um the passion of uh sir david amos in
meeting his constituents means that that
face-to-face contact should continue um
just very quickly your thoughts on that
i i would completely agree and i think
probably i didn't know sir david but i
doubt that he'd want even in these
tragic circumstances that that limits
that people that politicians have with
the public with their constituents to be
in in any way uh removed or constricted
because of this he he would want that
engagement probably to continue from
everything we've heard about him the way
he lived his life his
40 years as a parliamentary um uh
elected official
you know you could see that this ran
through him and he'd he'd want this to
continue in obviously a safe way but not
to diminish the mps the politicians and
their relationship and their direct
contact with their constituents but
we'll have to do it in a safer way okay
culver natalie stay there lots more
still to discuss we will now take a
break uh the prime minister
and the chancellor reportedly at odds
over how to tackle climate change that
is next on our agenda
[Music]
well welcome back you're watching the
press preview with me now natalie fay
and corvo ranger welcome back to both of
you um we will move away from sir david
amos there are other matters on the
front pages uh not least on the front
page of the observer you know roughly
two weeks to the cop 26 climate summit
natalie and suggestions of a rift about
how to and the implications of
um taking further steps towards net zero
uh yeah exactly so the the observer is
saying they've had confidential
documents leaked to them which um reveal
an extraordinary they say rift between
boris johnson and uh rishi sunak over
the effects of moving towards a
zero-carbon economy i mean uh to me it
seems to be no surprise that there's
another you know rao war of some sort
between the two of them um because um
you know sunak is basically saying don't
spend too much money and uh boris
johnson wants to be seen as you know the
green champion of the globe and a world
leader in the green economy across the
uk
um but i think what this article is
really forgetting and what it doesn't
really talk about is the effects that
all these measures are going to have on
normal people around the country um
you know a ban on gas boilers everyone
having to put brown sauce heat pumps in
uh that kind of thing that's expensive
for normal people so you know um let's
forget about these political bubble
arguments that are going on
actually um people like you know us you
me or the people who read
nottinghamshire live for example they're
going to be reading that thinking well
hang on how much am i going to have to
pay when i'm not allowed a gas boiler
anymore that's the important issue here
yeah and and and others um the article
in the observer quotes the prospect of
future tax rises uh and including as you
mentioned the serious economic damage to
the uk economy from these uh treasury
documents um we're at the crunch point
there'll be governments all over the
world wrestling with this as they
prepare to send their delegates to this
uh conference in glasgow i know you're
going there as well uh culver um this
this these are not easy decisions for
everybody as we move forward
it's not and but with this particular
report wasn't it ever thus a treasury
trying to stop a prime minister spending
money but um in this instance
i think there's there's no surprise that
uh the treasury is doing this but the
prime minister has a huge agenda to grip
around the environment i think there's a
tipping point that we've got to not just
in the politics of this but in people's
minds people really want to see change
happen i think we heard it several times
from different members of the monarchy
over this week uh the queen prince
william prince charles they're looking
for politicians to stop talking and
doing things and that's going to take
investment but i know one thing and in a
previous life when i was um boris
johnson's environmental advisor in
london
when we were looking at how do you
improve sustainable environmental
factors in the city yes it's about
spending money in terms of then it was
decentralized energy heating systems
retrofitting buildings because a lot of
co2 is produced by these things but also
creating the economy around these things
making sure jobs that the investment you
put in creates the right circular
movement of money so that even though
we're investing that's coming back
through skills jobs for people that then
makes it a more sound uh footing to go
forward on and it's not just a burden it
can't be a burden on society to make us
live in a more sustainable way it has to
be economically sustainable as well as
sustainable for the planet and that's
what i think you know i know this prime
minister is looking to do that and i
think the treasury will work with him to
get that uh
financed and structured the right way
you've got 30 seconds on the story at
the bottom of the sunday telegraph which
tackles pro-trans activists uh natalie
um yeah i mean i think we do need
guidance uh i think organizations need
clarity on what they should and
shouldn't be doing because at the moment
there is no clarity and i think women
need clarity as well so when they're
going to hospital or they're going into
prison they know what to expect from
that environment and who's going to be
there so i think it's a good thing that
we're going to be getting some clarity